broossooli is the morning host on 105.7
the zone our fox affiliate in Columbus
Ohio his show precedes this program we
talked to Bruce yesterday and thought
well 24 hours later any kind of update
for us Bruce on Urban Meyer's situation
well we have an independent committee
dan although when I went to college
independent didn't mean that you had
three Board of Trustee members on the
committee so I'm a little curious over
that one and I got to admit my eyebrows
went up when I saw this one of the
members on the committee is 90 years old
so I guess you must still have a lot of
game to be on something this important
and I think she's turning 91 here really
soon I don't know why that matters but I
did find it interesting when you tweeted
that out that they have somebody who's
90 years of age here what do you think
of this strategy if it's if it's a
strategy that everybody's quiet here and
it's almost like you know Ohio State's
trying to go dark here go covert and you
know let's get through the weekend let
the story fade a little bit at least
nationally locally it's still going to
be very important but footballs here you
got practice today is there any logic to
that kind of strategy here well I think
we saw it the big 10 kickoff lunch and
Dan what happens when a coach goes off
script and you know talk candidly Urban
Meyer boxed himself into a corner yeah
he has a perhaps a title 9 problem but
what he's really going to have a problem
with and what this committee I think is
trying hard to figure out a way out of
is how can they position his absolute
outright denial and dismissive nature of
knowing about the 2015 domestic violence
incident that was in question and how
can they position it that he wasn't
lying or yeah he lied but we're okay
with them lying it's bad but it's only
bad enough for four games I mean I think
are a lot of coaches in fear of their
jobs I think there are a lot of
administrators in fear of their jobs
because we're in an era where domestic
violence just doesn't get any wiggle
room from anybody
you still got to prove that he knew it
feels like it's it's hard to praise that
what the committee's gonna try to do
that that he knew about this and did
nothing about this or didn't know about
this
I think the timing is key you know how
we always kind of read into how long a
jury deliberates whether a person's
guilty or innocent I think if we get
something in a way of a press conference
is being called within to that's not
good if they go longer that tells me
they're looking at tax emails voicemails
trying hard to prove he didn't know but
Dan I gotta ask you man
football coaches work in a closed
environment wives they vacationed
together they shopped together wives are
there essentially single parents while
coaches are coaching do you really
believe like a what a coach's wife could
be abused other coaches wives wouldn't
know it or in this case we know the
other some of the coaches wives knew it
including the head coach's wife and for
three years she's not gonna tell the
head coach I mean do you buy that no no
I don't think anybody buys that but you
still have to prove it all this
committee had but it's still Urban Meyer
and it's not a wide receivers coach so
there's a little bit more latitude that
he's going to get I don't know if he can
keep his job I don't you know let's say
they found that he lied and he did know
and he didn't do anything about it you
know is that gonna be a fireable offense
you know I think that's probably what
it's gonna come down to I think you're
right and I think what this committee is
trying to do is be impossible I think
they're trying to figure out a way that
they can keep Urban Meyer and win the
story nationally yeah they're not gonna
win the story nationally unless they
fire him they're gonna win the story
locally if they keep him that's
absolutely a certainty the people
locally don't care they want to keep
winning they want to keep beating people
sixty five to seven they want to keep
going the playoffs I don't see a way
they can win the story nationally
because it's domestic violence it's the
appearance of him lying the pictures are
the pictures I just don't think there's
any way they win it nationally now the
question is do they care enough about
not winning it nationally to give him a
three or four gate suspension and try to
position it somewhere in the middle
perhaps win it a little bit nationally
and win it locally because he stays the
coach yeah I wondered about that and I
had some some feedback yesterday in the
coaching community and they said don't
rule out
kind of suspension for urban maybe it's
half the season but then they could
still keep him and still save face
because you know I was told by two
coaches yesterday they said this isn't
about locally this is about nationally
and it and you could kind of placate
both sides here and that you know they
said don't rule that out I don't know if
that would be precedent setting but you
know they didn't give Jim Tressel that
opportunity I don't know if they give
her banned Meyer that opportunity yeah
we're in a lot of different climate now
with domestic violence it's the
hot-button issue and but urban is loved
by the fans of different way than três
três was loved because of his image but
urban man he satisfies the bloodlust he
doesn't just beat you 2720 who beats it
57 to 7 if he can and so the fans have
gotten used to going to the playoffs two
out of every five years and the high
state has this weird dynamic Dan they
want to be Harvard in the classroom and
they want to be Alabama on the football
field and the two most successful
coaches they've had you know you know in
a long long time tres and Urban may both
be headed for the same fate and you got
to ask yourself maybe is it incompatible
being Harvard in the classroom and
Alabama on the football field because
the football portion of this just keeps
kind of finding interesting and
bothersome ways to embarrass the
University why was trestle expendable
coming off a 12 in one season
I lied to the NC double-a he lied to the
school he was a fraud and they just
finally got to the point where Sports
Illustrated cover story was the final
tipping point and they decided you know
the icon is important we've tried for
five months to keep him but eventually
the program and the school are bigger
than the icon and that's probably what
they're balancing on the scales right
now is does Urban Meyer and what he
gives you outweigh the consequences and
and the academics and the football are
not separate nothing drives giving like
success on the football field
they love building buildings they love
attracting top professors they love you
know their reputation in the academic
community and you would think okay well
what's football had to do with that man
nothing opens up the donors pocketbooks
like winning
on the football field so they got to be
very careful with this and I'm not sure
they're gonna be able to pull it off
because very few colleges Dan Baylor
Louisville Ohio State have been able to
get it right the first time on a crisis
management situation like this do you
think anything happens here over the
weekend no I don't think anything
happens over the weekend I think they
want to take a pause and kind of try to
figure this out and again the longer
this goes we'll tell me a lot what
they're trying to do I did read between
the lines on the selections on this
independent committee they have one of
the trustees is a consummate deal maker
and a very good you know bridger of gaps
so that tells me they're trying hard to
keep urban but again the domestic
violence part of it just may make that
an untenable goal to achieve thank you
Bruce we'll be in touch we appreciate
your time as always have a great weekend
thank you Dan
that's a broossooli morning host 105.7
2-zone our Fox affiliate in Columbus
Ohio for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]